- [Teacher] In multiple videos already,
we have talked about the
three branches of government
at the federal level.
You have the legislative
branch, which is Congress,
made up of two houses.
The House of Representatives
and the Senate.
You have the executive branch
with the President at the head
of the executive branch.
And of course you have the judicial.
Now what we're going to
focus on in this video is
in previous videos we've talked about that
the executive branch is in
charge of running the government
while the legislative
branch, they're the folks
who either write laws
or control the budget.
Now what we're going to do in this video
is dig a little bit deeper in terms of how
does Congress have oversight
over the executive branch.
When we think of the executive branch,
we often think of the President or maybe
the people who work around the president.
But the federal bureaucracy
is roughly 2.8 million people,
and we talk about that in other videos.
And so, how do we have oversight
over these 2.8 million people?
Well first of all, there is
a whole managerial structure
within the executive branch,
but on top of that, you
have the legislative branch
having oversight over
the executive agencies.
Over these 2.8 million people.
And there's two primary
means of this oversight.
The first one is Congress sets the budget.
This is often known as power of the purse.
And if Congress doesn't
like how a certain agency
is spending its money, they
might reduce the budget there.
If they really think that
some agency's doing a good job
or needs more resources, they
might give them more resources
in the next budget.
The other tool of
oversight that Congress has
is committee hearings.
And we have talked about
this in other videos.
But this is where the
appropriate committee
within Congress, it might
be within the Senate
or the House of Representatives,
will call in leaders
from the executive agency
that they are overseeing
to ask them questions.
Hey, why did this not go as we planned?
Or how do you deal with this situation?
Or why are you spending more money
than we thought you were
actually going to spend?
Now, to be clear, this is
not always going to work.
When we're talking about
2.8 million people,
there definitely might
be things that go on
within these executive agencies
that Congress, of course,
will not have complete control of
with just these two levers.
Or they might not even
know all of the details.
But they try to do the committee hearings
in order to get a reasonable understanding
of what's going on and then
leverage their budgetary powers
in order to have some level of oversight.
Now to get a feel for
what this looks like,
I'm about to show you an example
of a Senate committee hearing.
And this is a committee
hearing where they brought in
some folks from the FBI.
And what's interesting about this one,
this is not about national security.
This committee hearing is about relocating
or where they put the Federal
Bureau of Investigation
agency buildings.
And you can see that there's
definitely a tone of oversight
in this video.
- Mr. Matthews, I'm having a hard time
accepting what you're saying here.
So I'ma be perfectly blunt about that.
You now say a major reason for terminating
the original prospectus was that
the transfer of the Hoover Building,
something that you all
wanted, and we didn't want.
Congress didn't like that idea.
But you said it was
something you needed to do
to get it done.
So now we're supposed to
believe that's the reason
why you terminated for
something that you wanted.
Secondly, the consolidation,
one of the major reasons
for the consolidation on
costs is to save rental costs.
That's what you've told us all along.
That it's more expensive to have places
outside of the central location.
And now you're saying it's a wash.
Can you understand why
I'm hanging a hard time
accepting the information
you're presenting?
- Yes, Senator.
So with respect to your
first question, the issue--
- And quickly 'cause I heard-- we have
your written statement on the
transfer of the buildings.
I agree with you on the
transfer of the building.
Didn't makes sense.
But you insisted on it.
- Well I would say personally
I came here in August.
- Your agency insisted
on it in the prospectives
that they submitted,
they insisted that this
be part of the deal.
- Yes, they did, and I
suggest that was a mistake.
- And I've suggest that the information
you're giving us right now
maybe likewise a mistake.